the documentary blackfish continues to
be a success it was announced today that
Cyril Parks and Entertainment announced
an incredible loss in attendance and
revenues for their fourth quarter 2016
the revenues are down by tens of
millions of dollars and their attendance
is down by tens of thousands of people
in just the last quarter alone make no
mistake the public is fully aware of
what blackfish exposed and they are
completely disgusted by Cyril's behavior
in an attempt to discredit blackfish by
stating that has been debunked that
there was misinformation and completely
inaccurate oh really
what part of blackfish was inaccurate or
but has been debunked what the fact that
they showed a short video clip of orcas
being captured in the wild and they just
happen to not be up till acum
specifically so it's been debunked so
the rest of us saw that orcas have been
proven 100% conclusively to be sentient
beings they are completely self-aware
just like humans and that they know that
they are being enslaved that they know
that they are imprisoned and you have
them in a bathtub in a chlorinated
swimming pool for their entire lives
thus roam around in circles in a
concrete bathtub despite the fact that
in the wild they travel 100 miles a day
and that's right it is chlorinated
although of course SeaWorld will tell
you that they use a fraction of the
amount of chlorine that you'll find in a
public swimming pool so of course it's
safe the masses are awakened and they
are trying to send SeaWorld a message by
saying that they don't like your product
anymore they don't like the fact that
you're forcing these sentient beings to
do circus tricks for food we don't like
the fact that they have been robbed of
their families that they are being
caused incredible suffering both
physical and psychological because of
the treatment that they're receiving at
Ciro's now hold on I know that there's
many people that work for SeaWorld
trainers animal lovers I know there's so
many people there that love these
animals and treat them to the best of
their ability but the bottom line is
that they are imprisoned and they should
be released to the wild or at least a a
habitat you know in some sort of Bay or
Cove and many people have suggested this
but they refuse to do it people can't
stand the thought that the habitat that
were living in now is a fraction of the
size of the parking lots at SeaWorld
people can't stand the fact that
SeaWorld destroyed and discredited the
loving memory of Dawn Brancheau a
completely beautiful human being and
blamed her for her own death which is
clearly inaccurate
people can't stand the thought that
Kelly Clark who lied on the stand in a
courtroom in order to mitigate a lawsuit
that was happening because of Cyril's
negligence in her death that they
promoted her to director of training for
SeaWorld yes Kelly Clark so he was
demonstrated that they are a cover-up
artist and a liar and instead they
promote her it's disgusting
people are awakened to the fact that
they don't like Joel Manby the CEO of
SeaWorld who has gone on an aggressive
marketing campaign to try and discredit
blackfish and promote the image of zero
which is his job are you aware of the
Joel Manby his base salary is one
million dollars a year for the year
before last because he works for a
publicly traded company that he made
eleven point three million dollars
because you know bonuses and stock
options meanwhile orcas and dolphins are
suffering incredibly in their captivity
the word is out there is a global
awakening happening where people around
the world are figuring out that the way
things have been the last several
decades in this world aren't necessarily
the best way to go about life that we
want to embrace love in that we are
stewards of this planet as human beings
that we have special capabilities but
yet we treat orcas as if as if they're
less well guess what guys the public has
shown you and sent you a message that
they don't like your product anymore and
I suggest that you catch up with the
times and do the right thing
Joel Manby if you really are a good guy
like you claim to be like you've
marketed yourself which I'm starting to
think was just a gimmick that you've
quite literally took advantage and were
able to sell the the executives the
board of directors at SeaWorld in order
to make a freaking fortune good for you
right how about you do this dump your
SeaWorld socks ensure the release into a
habitat for the orcas and dolphins and
frickin quit and go drive you know write
on jet skis or move to it all-inclusive
resort for the rest of your life live
your life because make no mistake you
have the power to do the right thing
how many more millions of dollars you
need to make before you start embracing
the actual love that you preacher out
about and have written multiple books
about come on make no mistake this trend
is never going to stop it's only going
to accelerate in SeaWorld's days are
numbered I highly suggest that you
figure out another main attraction to
substitute the orcas and dolphins at
your facilities
I don't know install the roller coaster
do something else figure it out because
this
industry is dying people don't like it
and it's only going to continue down
this path so anyways guys I'll leave it
at that I highly recommend that you
don't attend any of cereal parks and
entertainment facilities because don't
forget it's not just funeral it's Busch
Gardens many other facilities look them
up you can google it look at the
Wikipedia page the own dozens of
facilities around the country anyways
guys I'll leave it at that
I'm Jimmy this is bright insight like
and subscribe I have many other videos
for you to enjoy on a whole wide variety
of topics take care everybody